so John is joining us now from Ukiah as
the Mendocino fires continue to burn at
an alarming rate listen John remember at
the beginning of the day yesterday we
were telling people that this Mendocino
fire was the fourth largest in state
history by the middle of my show it was
already the second largest and now today
the largest what's going on with the
Mendocino complex fires well certainly
it has been growing quickly now we have
to remember as it's growing in largely
rural areas in wilderness areas it
jumped over containment lines or areas
that they'd hoped might slow down this
fire but it moved very quickly with both
high temperatures and high and high
winds here and as the fire has grown
this this base camp here this fire base
camp has grown there's now some nearly
4,000 fire personnel are working on the
Mendocino complex fire here there's
there's a something like 400 at fire
engines we got 15 helicopters there's a
couple of big aircraft have been brought
in to try to contain this misfire this
has grown and grown as the fire has
grown the number of people coming in to
fight it has grown come from all over
the state here really to try to get this
blaze under control to try to contain it
yeah when I read it when I read 14,000
firefighters I sort of had to do a
double-take that served like a small
town of nothing but firefighters working
to beat back these fires you mentioned
that site that you're at the campsite
what's it like there you know what are
these firefighters going through well
certainly these firefighters now are
spending weeks and weeks away from home
on fires fire season in California is
now considered to be year round and we
have we've heard things like
firefighters spending a hundred ninety
days and more away from home in these
fire camps now these fire camps really
do become cities
it's about 14,000 firefighters across
the state here in the Mendocino complex
fire it's almost four thousand fire
personnel this is now a shift change
time there's firefighters out in the
line overnight watching the fire
watching for flare-ups overnight they
come in
to get some sleep during the day while
the well the daytime crews are now
getting some meals getting briefed
getting ready to head out back into the
hills here or where this fire continues
to grow now when we say the Mendocino
fire is the largest fire in California
history of sort of learning what that
means because it's not the most
dangerous fire can you sort of explain
the difference between this fire and
some of the other fires that are burning
in California well certainly this isn't
the most damaging fire in California
history by any means something like 75
residences have been destroyed and
clearly that's a disaster for those
people but there have been fires in
California in recent years that have
destroyed thousands of homes this fire
is burning in largely in remote a very
hilly rugged countryside there are
communities there are individual homes
there are certainly properties ranches
things like that in these hills but as
far as property damage goes this is this
is a rather minor fire as far as
property damage goes as far as the
amount of land that has been burned it's
clearly the largest in the in the
state's history but that doesn't mean
it's done the most property damage by
any means in your story you mentioned
what the president had to say about a
problem with water access and officials
there saying no the problem is climate
change in fact five of the largest fires
in California out of the five largest
ones that rather four of them have
burned since 2012 so you know the
experts that you've talked to do they
feel like this is the new norm or the
new norm is actually worse than what
we're seeing yes the new norm in
California is a fire season that goes
all year and fire officials say here
that the cause of that clearly is
climate change that summers are hotter
drought is more common that dries out
the landscape here it's normal in
California in most of California there's
very little rain little or no rain from
early May late April perhaps until
November that that is normal with higher
temperatures that dries out the
landscape even more makes it much more
ready to burn gives these firefighters a
much more difficult time when they're
when they're out in these fire lines in
your story you spoke to that gentleman
who said that he's got his shoes right
by his bed and you mentioned residents
really permanently changing their way
they live their lives because of these
fires what more can you tell us about
what residents are doing well certainly
one thing that people are being
encouraged to do here increasingly in
California is be sure that you have
defensible space around your home
the recommendation is that for a hundred
feet around your home you should clear
out trees brush anything that could make
it difficult for firefighters to get in
and protect your home give them some
space to protect your home a hundred
feet of clearance also neighborhoods are
are making an effort to clear out trees
just generally in the neighborhood to
make sure that there's ways to get out
should fire come in that you know in an
evacuation route
I usually often evacuation in many areas
is much easier by foot than by Road
because you have fire trucks racing in
so be ready have a plan to how you'll
get out you should the terrible should
the terrible thing happen oh man well
that is good advice but it is not gonna
stop that blaze and I just look at the
firefighters behind you and hearing how
they're working for weeks on end these
are truly truly heroes John Blackstone
thank you so much